cuz I saw tiger
in the midst of the ongoing corona virus
pandemic it's safe to say but been a
Netflix show Tiger King have given us
all something else to talk about now if
you haven't seen it yet the docu-series
takes us on this unimaginable journey
it's the wild world of big cats
featuring too good to be true stories
from independently owned exotic zoos
including Joe exotics GW Animal Park in
Oklahoma
Ignatz bacon good-looking that party and
have fun I don't think we're dead
blowing today so it's no surprise that
Joe has quickly become a cultural
phenomenon and maybe your favorite
country artist that's right I think the
best gift this show has given us is
watching Joe lip-sync his country music
videos and there's more to be found
online which is just so entertaining so
let's take a look at some of Joe's most
exotic music videos Justin my first
album I saw Tiger there's 28 songs and
16 music videos
no song will be here kitty-kitty it's
the ultimate diss track featuring Joe's
theory that Carol Baskin killed her
missing husband and fed him to her cats
and of course the music video brings of
accusations to life with a Carol
look-alike feeding raw meats to a caged
tiger
[Music]
you
[Music]
now in the upbeat pretty woman lover the
self-proclaimed gay gun-toting cowboy
with a mullet things about being a hit
with the ladies but needless to say it's
super entertaining and does not
disappoint
Joe is seen being chased around by women
while sitting on the back of a
motorcycle and while riding in the back
of a stretch Dodge Charger limo because
of course mean while I saw Tiger is one
of Joe's the slower ballads here we have
the iconic shot of the tiger king on his
truck playing his guitar now some would
say that this song is ironic given that
he's singing about letting Tigers roam
their lands and he owns a private Zoo
[Music]
I saw Tigers
Tigers
because you love me has to be one of
Joe's greatest videos purely for the
fact that he convinced his zoo guests to
be featured in the background I mean not
something to be proud of if you made it
in one of the tiger Kings videos
[Music]
and last but certainly not least my
first love it's a sweet ode to Joe's
first husband John Finley I mean every
country singer has to have a romantic
love song and it was just revealed that
Joe exotic doesn't actually sing his own
songs guys nobody who's more shocked or
heartbroken than I am in a new interview
with Vanity Fair Rick Kirkham the
producer of Joe exotic TV admitted that
the songs were sung by Clinton Johnson
band members Vince Johnson and Danni
Clinton who have since passed away and
according to Rick Joe's lack of musical
talent was a running joke on set telling
the magazine quote one time Joe got a
little bit drunk and high and we
actually coaxed him into singing part of
one of the songs he couldn't even hold a
tune it was just so ludicrous but we are
not gonna let this stop us from enjoying
Joe's iconic music videos let us know
your favorites in the comments below